merci Monsieur le le Président Madame et
monsieurs les ministres monsieur le
Président de la Commission madame et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues le projet de loi contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
voulu par le gouvernement répondait à
l'exigence d'adaptation de notre droit
aux nouvelles réalités que notre pays
connaît dans le domaine migratoire la
situation demande en effet aujourd'hui
de mieux réguler les flux de mieux
protéger les Français contre les
délinquants étrangers et de mieux
intégrer grâce à l'affirmation de nos
valeurs au travail et à l'usage de notre
langue les étrangers aant vocation à
rester sur le territoire national au
sein de notre assemblée saisie en
première lecture les débats ont été
riches et constructifs ils ont permis
l'adoption d'un texte que la majorité du
groupe RDPI a voté validant ainsi une
démarche de de construction qui devait
se poursuivre dans le cadre de la
navette parlementaire car oui je l'avais
exprimé à cette tribune certaines
dispositions contenues dans le texte
voté par notre assemblée ne nous
convenaent pas et notre vote positif ne
valait pas quitus il en était ainsi tout
particulièrement pour la suppression de
laame le travail législatif était
néanmoins bien lancé pour doter notre
pays de la législation dont il a
besoin malheureusement une coalition
aussi étrange qu'étéroclite a vu le jour
à l'Assemblée nationale pour mettre en
difficulté le gouvernement
et finalement provoquer une brusque
accélération des échanges qui aurait dû
en toute hypothèse avoir lieu entre nos
deux chambres notre groupe a abordé
cette commission mixte paritaire en
ayant toujours la même priorité à
l'esprit aboutir à un texte équilibré
qui soit une réponse efficace aux
besoins du pays et aux attentes des
Français un accord était impératif pas
seulement pour le gouvernement et la
majorité présidentielle pas seulement
pour l'ELR mais pour le pays tout entier
ces échanges nous les avons eu sous le
regard attentif des français puisque 67
% d'entre eux se sont déclarés
favorables à ce texte sur
l'immigration cependant chacun
s'accordait pour dire que certaines des
dispositions votées par le Sénat comme
certaines dispositions votées par la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nécessité d'être réécrite s'agissant de
l'Ame nous avons tenu compte à la CMP
des conclusions sans équivoque du
rapport rédigé par Monsieur Stéphan et
Evin ce rasort estime que l'aide
médicale d'État est utile et maîtrisé
c'est ce qui nous a conduit à revenir
sur la souppression de laame proposé par
le texte du Sénat compte tenu de
l'engagement de notre première ministre
d'engager dans les meilleurs délais une
réforme concernant les prestations
sociales le texte du Sénat conditionnait
toutes les aides non contributies à une
résidence de 5 ans sur le territoire
national elles ont été réduites les les
les délais à la fois ont été réduits et
les périmètres également les périmètres
des aides concerné s'agissant de la
nationalité nous avons supprimé CIN
articles qui à nos yeux étaient
problématiqu restera par contre et nous
l'assumons la déchéance de nationalité
pour les binationaux condamnés pour
homicide sur personnes dépositaire de
l'autorité publique pour l'hébergement
d'urgence là encore le texte du CTA
n'était pas vraiment applicable en
l'état il faut bien le dire car il
risquait de mettre à la rue plus de
150000 personnes du au lendemain pour
l'obtention du titre de séjour étranger
malade enfin nous nous en resterons à la
rédaction de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale à nos ux plus
justes et plus équilibré compte tenu des
débats constructifs et du texte auquel
nous avons réussi à aboutir en
commission mixte paritaire sous l'gide
de nos rapporteurs sous l'gide des deux
présidents de des commissions des des
lois de nos assemblées notre groupe
votera dans sa majorité pour le projet
de loi présenter les conclusions de la
CMP je vous
remercie